this is an Asian stain of the kidney  showing the structures like glomerulus  over here this kind of structure you can  see is the Bowman's capsule  Bowman's capsule  and within it you can see this structure  over here represents the glomerulus  and over here this structure is the  Bowman space apart from that you can  also see two types of Loops like one  sort of loop is over here that you can  see within it the borders are very much  I mean irregular  and this irregular border tells you that  this is proximal convoluted tubule which  has brush water and hence irregular  border on the other hand you have other  type of tubes like this one where you  have the inner inner lining very smooth  and well demarcated this is DCT or  digital convoluted tubule and the smooth  boundary is because they don't have any  brush bodies